[Music]
there's a drunk man at my door
threatening my life
go ahead okay
all right let's get up i'll go again put
my shit here i'm getting my gun just
ridiculous if he comes in my door do i
get a chance to shoot him
sir
yeah do you know this now
yes okay
yeah
i don't know
you don't know nope how old is he
thirty
thirty does he white block his fan
occasion
hello
white
what color shirt is he wearing
no sir
what color pants
blue jean
does he have any weapons
no
so you said he's been drinking
yeah and he's ripping
my screen door off
as you see
okay so he's ripping the screen door off
bringing that off yeah he's doing
properly to my house sorry
ripping the screen door off and my wife
wants to go get pizza and she's on her
way back so i'm gonna have to go out
there and deal with him
so you better hurry up since he tested
my wife i'm gonna see them
what's your first name
what's your last name
can you spell that for me
take a minute
and what's your date of birth
okay and are your doors locked
yeah
but my wife's coming up
okay can you tell your wife not to drive
in the driveway just so you avoid
confrontation until law enforcement gets
there
yeah
okay i'm gonna enter a call for service
okay
hello are you still there
yeah okay i'm gonna get a call enter for
service okay
thank you thank you
number one
yeah i called 911
a hitch now and he moved over to my
neighbor's house
and he's in their yard so he has a
weapon
he has a what
a hitch from the truck with the ball on
it
can you sell the front yard
they're telling he's in the neighbor's
front yard now he's looking for a fight
do you know the address
the second house and from orangeville
okay
on the on the right second house on the
right all right they should be there
soon they were down the street okay
yep
all right thanks bye
[Music]
9700
um
[Music]
[Music]
very good
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
i got you guys
yeah we'll take it for now
are we going to create this one
uh
you see him
but i said we're utl on the street i'm
going to go to
rp's house
he's sitting in a
car yeah
now
says he's in the grass by that car
but
i think your husband wants you to go
home
yeah i just parked here go ahead there
he is
hi sir hey don't move okay
hey put that down put that down
barry 73 one at gunpoint uncooperative
put that down put that down are you
gonna get tased
you're gonna get tased
put it down man put it down
put it down
put it down
put it down
put it down
put it down
down get on the ground get on the ground
get on the ground now
get on the ground
you got cons
okay
hey don't move okay hey put that down
put it down
hey put it down
put it down
put it down
hold it down
put it down
and i tell you again
it's cool
put it down put it down
get on the ground get on the
ground get on the ground now
get on the ground
you got calm
yep
hey
put it down
[Music]
get on the ground now
he's on the ground
yep